هو الب البر الوحيد معسكر جمال ها
الم بيجي من الصبح من 8 للساعه 12 كل
معسكر جبال بيجي بعب من ه يعني شو بده
يلحقك منه مبيلك جرد تبيلك دلو تعبي لك
قلم
اصفر فوضع يعني وضع الميه صعب جدا غير
انها ميه مش صالحه للشرب الاحى يعني يعني
يعني يا دوبك انها تكون للصالح للغسيل
للجلي هي وضع هي الوضع الليف يعني هي بس
وضع الميه يعني بس فقط صارت وضع هي الميه
سيب من غير الواسطه يعني بس وضع الميه
يعني ه مش مقينا يعني اللي ثلاث ايام بروح
بشتري رطل بالرطل الطحين من جبال للبلد 70
شيكل للرطل حنا يمل على اضاء جبال للبلد
ما
في يعني هي الم الملوثه ب تتاثر على
الحيوان مش ب تتاثر على الاطفال ف بالك
بالاطفال بتاثر عليه نحس بتاثر على الكبار
المرض المزمنين اللي معه ضغ السكر طبعا
الميه الملوثه شيء طبيعي لا تصلح للتغسيل
مش للشرب للتغسيل لا تص لكن مجبورين ايش
هي وضعنا ايش
n